hello everyone and welcome back to the
paul morphy saga we are continuing the
1858 uh simultaneous exhibition in paris
while we're we're waiting for morpheus
to match with daniel harvest to continue
and here we have our third uh
opponent uh it's anri boucher and very
little is known about this gentleman
uh and uh well no we don't know uh
a lot about most of the people murphy
played against uh but it was known that
he was a frequent
member of the cafe de la regence
chess club the there was no chess club
it was just you know
people who casually went there every day
and played chess
so he is uh one of the opponents in
morphy's blindfold simultaneous
exhibition and
this game is uh just out of this world
as you might have imagined from seeing
the thumbnail
uh it's no no clickbait that actually
happened and it's just uh amazing how
morphy does such things especially uh
when playing blindfold so without
further ado
let's check it out and uh well you will
definitely
enjoy this one so morphe with the white
pieces opens with
e4 for those of you who are maybe new to
chess when you're holding a simultaneous
exhibition
uh usually the one giving the
simultaneous exhibition will start with
the white pieces so e5 we have knight to
f3 and the d6 we have the philidor's
defense and the morphe no stranger to
the philidor
uh goes uh d4 strikes in the center
we have e captures on d4 most certainly
not bishop to g4
if you know what i'm talking about so e
captures on d4 morphe grabs back with
the queen queen captures on d4 and now
knight to c6 attacking morphy's queen
with bishop to b5
pinning that knight and the bishop to d7
and this is all
very very standard stuff and this is
still being played today in 2020 in top
tier tournament so nothing out of the
ordinary here
captures captures and now bishop to g5
and nowadays knight the c3
is the main line but okay bishop to g5
attacking the queen
and boucher goes for f6 blocking that
bishop and while this is all very nice
the problem is
with d6 on the board and with f6 on the
board
uh you've uh well uh weakened the e6
square for the rest of the game and this
is now a problem and the morphe will now
do his best to try and take advantage of
this uh weekend e6 square if you could
put
put a piece in there maybe a night it's
gonna be great so this is morphe's plan
now
we have bishop to h4 getting the bishop
out of harm's way and
knight to h6 so just continuing
development knight to c3
uh and now of course bishop to e7 bushey
also wants the castle we have castles by
both players castles castles
and now uh morphe continues with his
plan of getting something to that e6
square and he starts with
queen to c4 with check that's not the
correct arrow
freeing up the d4 square from the knight
and from d for the knight can easily
come to e6 so king to h8
uh getting the king out of check and now
knight to d4
uh attacking the bishop and also
preparing uh
this uh knights to come to e6 now uh you
could go bishop to d7 that's always an
idea
but here we actually have queen to d7 uh
but
uh everything up to this point has
already been played before and i know
this sounds very crazy because this is
1858 but
this this is even for those days this
was uh maybe not standard theory but it
has been seen before and in top tier
play
it was played in a game between uh love
intel and harvest so our two
good friends uh in 1853 in the great
london tournament so five years before
this one
we already mentioned that harvest
visited london uh five years uh prior to
his match with morphe
and uh this is where that game took
place and in that game
uh harvest did play bishop to d7 but
here uh
boucher goes for queen to d7 and it is
only now as of move 12 that we have uh
not only a completely new game but a
position that was never reached again
so here morphe continues with the
development rook 8 to d1
and now rook to f7 preparing to bring
the other rook into
the game uh we have f4 by morphe now
preparing f5 to cement this e6 square
for his knight
uh and a5 now grabbing more space on the
queen side morphy says no problem i'm
just gonna play f5 and now
this e6 square is really really weak and
the morphe will put a knight there
and it's just going to be torture from
then on so rook
f back to f8 for some reason
uh and now knights the e6 morphe just uh
gets his knight to this beautiful
outpost attacks the rook so rook to g8
this was black's plan
and now a4 uh here uh a4 is such a
such a beautiful move that if you look
at this position black doesn't really
have any
uh active plans there is nothing to go
for everything is nicely defended
uh but if he can get this b5 moving then
it's going to be very good for black so
morphy
says okay i can do some rook lifts i
could go rook d3 rook h3 maybe rook f3
rook g3 rook
anything but morphe just plays a4 and
this is uh
such a high quality move for those days
to play such a move really shows how
how far ahead of his time morphy was as
now
uh he even breaks this counter play
there is no b5 now and
what do you play here now with black so
black does the only thing
uh he he can he needs to shift this
knight back into the game either via the
f7 square or via the g4 square to go to
go to e5 and that's what he does knight
to g4
and now uh queen to e2 morphy attacks
the knight
forces him to come to e5 knights to e5
and now bishop to g3
again uh if bishop captures uh knight
comes you will not be able to capture
bag because the queen is on b7 so
boucher starts with queen to c8 but
morphy
still trades with bishop captures d
captures and
now only now that everything has been
set in motion rook to f3 now the rook is
coming to h3 and it's not going to be
pretty
so bishop to d7 now trying to eliminate
this knight from e6 and if black can do
this
then black will be fine but morphe of
course doesn't allow it rook to h3
and now morphy is setting a trap
basically if you eliminate the knight
now bishop captures then you run into
rook captures an h7
check king captures and now queen to h5
of course is checkmate
so uh there will be no capturing of the
knight here on e6 so here h6
uh preventing this but now comes the
move that completely shatters black's
defenses and that is queen to d2
queen to d2 with a double attack on the
bishop so you either lose a piece or you
allow
rook captures an h6 which is just deadly
and also
runs into checkmate to check this is
force and queen captures and h6 will be
checkmate
so after queen to d2 abusheh says all
right
i mean it's only one piece he plays king
to h7
and now morphy grabs it queen captures
on d7 grabbing a piece and now morphies
up material
and black can very easily even resign
this on the spot but black says
uh it's only one piece and morphe is
playing blindfold so i'm going to
continue maybe maybe something good can
still happen for me and he goes bishop
to d6
blocks this rook's defense of the queen
and now he kind of
forces a queen trade but not really
because here morphy actually has a
forced
checkmate in six so feel free to pause
the video and
try to find this uh amazing idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on sacrificing both
your rook
and your queen and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures an h6 now uh the g pawn
cannot capture the g
pawn is pinned so you have to capture
with the king this is the only move
and after king captures an h6 now comes
the move you had to see in order to play
rook captures on h6 and that's
rook to d3 a beautiful queen sacrifice
but now when you see it
the pawn guarding the g6 square and the
knight car
covering both the g7 and the g5 with
these three squares
not available to the black king rook the
h3 will be checkmate so if
the queen is accepted uh just rook to h3
is checkmate the black king has no
squares
so uh after this rook the d3 of course
uh boucher
said all right maybe the queen can be
captured just yet i'm gonna play king to
h5 now uh but now morphe just goes for
queen to f7 with check king to h4
and now rook the h3 with check king to
g4
and now queen to h5 and this is now
checkmate and we reached the position
from the thumbnail
and now you know how such a such a
position can even occur because if
someone just shows you this it's like
how did this king get here i mean which
path did he take i mean this is covered
you can't touch the g6 square how did
how did the king get the g4 but now you
know
uh and uh i mean what i mean this is
just a brilliant brilliant game
and uh you know uh definitely one for
the for the history books and it of
course
is featured in most of history books
that feature more of his games
but it's really really amazing uh how
morphy could create such masterpieces
you know
while playing blindfold against players
of reasonable you know
reasonable strength so
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
that that's already the third game we've
shown from the blindfold simultaneous
exhibition we are going to
show some more as they are quite quite
enjoyable uh so hope you're ready for
that uh i would like to thank
uh mao mara mao unleashes alex s
mahendra tribune surah
yagadesh gunapanamath and please don't
mention my name for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day